hey hello everybody and welcome to
episode number 29 of my 1hour flipping
challenge today I'm going to be doing
something a little bit different I'm
going to flipping items suggested by you
on my last um challenge video I asked
for some suggestions for the next video
and most of them are bad some of them
are good uh but let's have a bit of fun
with it and see what we come up with all
right let's get started okay guys we're
about to get started we have 20 mil
we're going to do for this um and uh
this is based on the items you guys
suggested I think 20 mil should be
adequate uh so there's a lot of
suggestions so thank you guys for all
that now I've sorted them into
categories uh best decent and bad and
I'll throw the whole list of items into
the description cuz there's quite a few
of them uh the best items I thought were
uh the infinity boots someone suggested
uh the dragon Harpoon k d robes Mystic
Rob top gral dragon two Ender uh the
ranging potion I thought would be good
someone suggested Z scales cannonballs
and another person suggested Dragon
boots dragon curs and the dragon dagger
uh for decent items I just threw some
kind of random ones in here like the
taiana teleport uh limber root Dragon
arrows Tunas CAD stuff like that that is
okay uh not awful and then there's a
whole bad category which includes
potatoes rases rake I suggest that Arrow
shafts feathers Iron Warhammer blue
party hats pretty badge because of the B
limit uh shrimp vials I mean you get it
bunch of bad items people suggested but
I brought this upon myself so that's
totally cool and yeah so that's just a
general overview of the items I have to
work with and let's go so we have 20 mil
and uh while I did have a quick look at
the dragon Harpoon it didn't look like
it had a huge margin on it and it would
take a lot of our Capital to do it so I
think I'm going to pass on that uh next
up is the infinity boots now the limit
it's saying is 24 so that's a pretty
high limit I think I might just manually
check this item and we'll write this
right down beside it
1505 and
1495 not a huge margin but still not bad
and uh we'll do uh four of those to
begin with and we'll just write this
margin down quickly okay next up is the
elder chaos top someone suggested we'll
try buying it for 555 it's not a huge
margin but we do have a good amount of
money uh Elder chaos
top and try for 555k we'll just do one
of those cuz they don't trade a lot um
next up the granite
mall is another good item that someone
suggested and don't worry I will do some
bad ones as well I'm just going to start
off with some good ones to get get me
started 3499 into
33750 uh so it looks like the G limit is
70 I've actually never flipped this item
for surprisingly uh so that's a pretty
decent margin for the price 33750 that
is a almost a 1K margin uh so we yeah
we'll definitely do I'll happily do I'll
do 65 of those leave a little bit of
room for later uh that'll be actually
pretty good margin on that dragon two
ERS I'm just kind of going down list
here dragon two enders I have done
pretty slow uh ranging potions I put on
here because I think I could attempt to
decant these or just flip them straight
up and one thing I want to mention while
I'm checking this here is there were
some other suggestions that people um
placed on the video but they are vague
or weren't for a specific item so I only
took things that people suggested that
were specific I mean people said like
seeds and do this or do free to play uh
but I wanted specific items and maybe I
didn't articulate that properly which
may be my fault but I only took items
that were specifically named because
otherwise it would be too much of a
broad category uh so I thought that just
get out of the way uh ranging potions
226 into 2322 that is actually really
good we'll try doing
a we'll start with 500 I don't know how
many these trade a day I'll have to
quickly have a look looks like every
half an hour there's about 2k traded uh
so we could probably get all one 2K
traded for the buying limit but I think
we'll just do 500 for now Cuts our money
pretty much in half um next up I think
we might do the dragon
dagger
p++ again we're just going to price
check this
item uh
27300 into 2542 that is pretty good
that's a 2K margin uh on a item like
that is very good going to do another 65
of these 100%
25483 sounds good and uh okay we'll do
one of the decent items taiana teleport
going to give that a
try um let's have a look at the
quantities first actually uh so it's
looking at about 100 per hour we could
look to do uh which isn't awful but I
don't know if we're going to do this
item does look like we have a couple
Infinity boots coming through uh so
we're selling this for a 10K profit on
each uh 1505 and we'll just pop them
down here I
guess
505k
roughly
and Gran malls kind of stopped coming
through but we'll leave those in there
for just a little bit and dragon dagers
I thought would come through a lot
quicker we'll be a little patient I
guess okay really simple flip uh dragon
simitar has a 700 GP margin on it uh not
huge but
but um I think it's still going to be
decent and uh we'll do just 40 for now
it's kind of expensive uh so 700 GP
margin on that they should trade quickly
uh we did sell the infinity boots
already uh 10K margin on that isn't too
bad and we have 7 mil left and one offer
slot although we may switch up some of
these items all right cads have a one g
or two GP margin on them so I guess
we'll do cads and uh we do 5K cdes sure
and I think we we have a good amount of
items in here uh the infinity boots did
sell off nice that's a 20K first real
flip coming through all right the dragon
boots have a very nice margin
4K um that's excellent we'll
do well we'll do 30 of these for now uh
that would be awesome looks like we have
the Elder chaos Hood coming in for
555k I don't recall what we I just
opened League of Legends damn it all
right Elder C head uh we bought for
5555 and we're looking to sell
for yeah let's try
560 it's not that great
um
[Music]
562 and uh oh what okay we instant sold
it for 564 that's interesting okay so we
have the Elder Chaos Head coming through
again for 555 not bad we'll Jack that
maybe to 570 or 569 I don't
know um Dragon boots are coming through
and dragon dagger p+ pluses I'm not sure
what we wanted to toss in this offer
slot um I think we're going to pull the
Grand Mall for now cuz it's not going
through we'll have to recheck that
absolutely ooh nice 29 30k for that
we'll definitely sell those quickly
off
2998 um how much are we get on each one
of those right now um almost
4.5k uh on each one 4.5 time 40 is going
to be about 120 130k on those items
which is great all right so we have the
infinity boots coming in for
1505 uh which isn't bad Elder chaos top
for 569 that is probably our most
profitable item surprisingly uh go buy
another we'll go for two of those we
have a lot of money right now uh the
Grand Mall we did recheck and we
mentioned um yeah we'll do it I mean we
don't have anything else our money's on
right now and uh it's not a huge margin
but we'll try try 50 of them Dragon
boots have almost all come through and I
kind of want to start selling them off
and we might just pull something else
out that's not working because we do
have 22 of
them and if we reprice check them
they're going for still 4K margin pretty
well so we'll definitely want to start
selling those off all right I feel like
I want to try the ranging potion again
uh it should trade a lot more than it
was maybe we got undercut right away 22
20 is what we'll buy him for yeah we'll
toss him in here we took out the coides
cuz they are kind of [__] uh but yeah I
know whoever said that knew that
probably so I hope he's not offended
we'll do a thousand I just realized the
Mystic Rob Bott Rob bottoms are on here
uh they trade
maybe 50 every half an hour or so uh but
a pretty good margin on them might be
worth doing
2K and uh well we don't have anything
else we're investing our money in right
now so we'll just do 50 of these why not
and uh I'm not really sure what the
limit is I'm assuming around 70 but
that's just kind of a random guess now
we do have a bunch of items nearly
coming in in total that being the
granite mall and Elder chaos tops have
all come in and we're selling those for
569 uh mind you we don't actually know
what the margin is we didn't price check
that but we're just guessing Okay all
the dragon SARS and the Elder chaos Hood
top sorry have come through uh 569 we'll
definitely pop some more of these in
there cuz that is well that 208k flip
nothing wrong with that we'll maybe toss
a couple more quantity in of
that and we'll do three three seems good
and dragon SARS have all come through
68k rebind them for
roughly and uh let's see we can sell
them for it's been probably 10 minutes
since we started the offer
68700 still a 700 GP profit isn't awful
by any means
and uh the granite malls have all come
through for 34201 plus a little bit of
them earlier for a different price but
kind of a negligible amount
honestly and again only getting 500 on
each of
these not the greatest but I only have a
certain amount of items to work with
from wait
what okay yeah sorry that included some
from earlier I was wondering there's no
way we got that much money off of that
but it'll probably be 50 or 60k from
that not terrible okay wow all the
ranging potions came through once for
2220 that's nice uh ranging
potion uh we can sell for
2347 uh that's actually a pretty decent
flip 23
47 and that's
2351 from
2220 but
130k 30k which isn't uh is actually
really good actually all right dragon
dagger p+ pluses have come through 42 of
them and I think we actually made pretty
good bank on each one of these 5K in
each uh which would equate
to 200k jeez I don't know why that was
so difficult hey okay what about limbert
Roots another item that's on my well
it's on my decent list uh we'll try
2,000 I don't know if again how many of
these are traded but they're used a lot
in her blor so I have to imagine uh
there must be some traded today Lim
route
for oh yeah shitloads of these traded
that's good uh that actually might be a
decent item limit is saying
13k uh actually a really good free play
item honestly never tried this before I
think with the rest of our money we'll
buy some more ranging potions cuz that
is a really good margin on them I just
didn't know how quickly they buy and
sell but that seems decent to me all
right Elder chaos Hood our top coming in
555 we have all of them now and we're
going to try sell them for 569 once
again o 569 sorry uh so 1707 from
1665 is a 40K profit and not too bad
okay I think I'm going to straight up
pull out the msic Rob bottoms uh cuz we
do have 31 of them but it's been buying
for a while and 26 minutes left seems
like an adequate amount of time to sell
them off um so Mystic Rob
bottoms are going to sell for
56447 and we bought them for about 2k
profit is going to be pretty good 56
445 okay just took a break to go eat a
pickle and we got the ranging potions
coming through finally that is a decent
profit on that once again 130k roughly
uh more coming through slowly uh we
got kind of a bunch of offers halfway
done so I we only have 20 minutes left
so we're going have to start wrapping
this up pretty soon but one thing I
think I'm going to do more of is the
Mystic sorry not the Mystic
the infinity boots I know it didn't work
out that well before and I really don't
want to price check this again but
honestly this item does trade quite a
bit uh well let's just pop it in here
for was it 14.95 before um we'll try 14
1985 and we'll go for a couple of these
okay I [__] up I instantly bought
those uh for
1478 uh I guess we'll sell those back
hopefully quickly here1 1478 999 okay
like I said that won't be a huge deal
that was only uh 5 seconds or something
until they sold uh so we I guess we'll
try that again with only one well we
know the price now so we have to be so
careful uh we'll try [__] does that
button even do uh we'll try putting it
in for a bit lower
66k and three again I guess okay a
couple things are coming through
Infinity boots have all bought so uh
coming through really quickly now
1466 and we're selling them for
1478 well we're like 1479 honestly minus
little bit coinage there so 4436 and we
bought them for 43
98 well it's a 40K profit not good but
it is quick and uh we need to be quick
cuz we only have 17 minutes left also
the dragon boots finally sold okay
Infinity boots fall come through so
quickly 1478 and we'll go back and buy
another three of
those and all came through at once which
is nice Elder C Hood top sorry uh have
all come through as well 16 minutes left
we'll try buying another three but not
sure how likely that's going to be but
we can we won't lose much either way and
uh gr malls have Stu stopped coming
through and these Dragon citar will have
sold off by the time we're done I
believe which is nice okay so the
granite malls have sold awesome uh
those are not in our offer history
anymore it's okay um the dragon some
tars have sold I don't think those will
be in our offer history mysic Rob
bottoms have sold as we're actually
clearing out our inventory quite quickly
now and I okay they're here
1683 we sold them for
1806 minus one pair so about 100K
roughly uh so not awful okay so 10
minutes left uh we just ditched cowes
because they're kind of [__] again sorry
uh Elder chaos hoods have come through
for 555 um we'll sell them for 569 but
we don't have much time left and I feel
like
the infinity boots have changed in price
again so I think we're just going to
pull the money out and say that's an
item well flipped ranging potions we'll
pull out uh cuz I don't think we're
buying any more of those
either
ranging
potion for
2355 that's again pretty much what we
had when we started this flip so it's a
really good item to flip right now all
right guys we have 5 minutes remaining
uh but looks like all our items actually
did come through uh Lums did sell for
289 which is insane ranging potions
coming through just kind of scrap some
of those items uh the other chaos Hood
we did get another successful flip on
which is awesome but I don't think we
have enough time to do another one on
each one of those we got um
1665 put 40K on each one of those and I
think we'll just pull the Zoro scales
cuz we haven't had a single one come
through and we only have four minutes
remaining so in an unconventional
fashion I'm just going to end uh for
minuts early just because there's
nothing really left for me to do uh only
bad items left and even at that 4
minutes is not enough time to flip them
anyway so uh that's it guys so you can
kind of see how I tried to do some of
the what I qualified as bad items and um
you can see obviously they didn't work
so I thought this might actually be
useful anyway to so you can kind of see
the difference between what I classify
as a good item and a bad item and even
the decent items uh while they're might
be worth doing over a more long-term
period of time but for my challenge not
gonna be good so you can really tell all
I really flipped was the best items I
could find amongst the list you guys
gave me but anyway now for the reveal
how much did I actually make off of your
guys' suggested items 751k which is
pretty damn good honestly uh from a 20
mil start not bad uh mainly a lot of
that profits coming from well the
infinity boots uh Mystic Rob bottoms
Grand all I mean it's actually spread
out over quite a few different items
there wasn't one item that was really
just by far the best I'd say four or
five of them were probably the best and
then another four or five moderately
good flips uh leading to about 751k
which I think is pretty good so hope you
guys enjoyed I appreciate your
suggestions and uh we might do something
like this in the future and uh on a last
very last note uh the giveaway will be
in the next video so for those of you
who entered on my uh last Bond and 7h
hour video uh I will be giving away the
bond from that video in tomorrow's video
not tomorrow's video maybe the next
video anyway I'm rambling see you guys
hope you guys have a good night
[Music]
bye